- [Woman] If you had to
describe yourself in one word
what would that word be?
- A contradiction.
- [Woman] Cool.
- I think I'm pulling from the
very opposite sides which give
me real balance.
("Unstoppable" by This Is Wolff)
("Contemplating"
by Charlie MixWelh)
I'm not losing
player and thus
I'm willing to
make the hard calls.
But I'm not willing
to do it emotionless
and as a corporation.
- [Woman] Yeah.
- I care what everybody thinks
about me and I don't care what
anybody thinks about me.
- Without--
- 30 cases, right.
- Yeah.
- Okay. How's this doin'?
You see where I'm going?
- [Brandon] Mhmmm.
- Can you debate
that with my dad and
see what you guys come up with?
I think, to me, when you
walk in to the store...
- [Tyler] Wednesday.
Gary's been here
two weeks straight.
Which has not
happened in the last,
probably two years or so.
It's been pretty sweet.
Getting a lot of
good internal meetings.
A lot of good
Team Gary meetings.
Really able to push
things on a VaynerMedia level.
And that means for me just
making sure in
tune with all that.
It's a lot of work to
just get through the day.
Move through the day, meeting
to meeting, things are happening
on the fly at all time.
Juggling has been much
like travel logistics or
anything like that.
And now, I made a comment
the other day about it's like
watching silent movie sometimes
when I sit outside the office
and see what's
going on on the inside.
I can read the room
in two seconds.
And so, there's
just a lot of that.
Balancing that with
his inbox, my inbox,
quick phone calls,
scheduling meetings,
understanding what's going
on in the world around him,
Office of the CEO,
all the different pods,
SVPs, who's got to meet,
who's got to get on
the phone for two seconds.
Okay, push that meeting,
move that so things are good.
It's fun.
There's so many different
variables of like when he's on
the road how the job works.
When he's here
how the job works.
When he's about to get on
a flight how the job works.
When he's fully
in tune with email,
when he's not
fully in tune with email.
It's been heavy focused on
internal VaynerMedia over the
last two weeks and we've
made a ton, a ton of strides.
And then the next six weeks,
he's on the road tremendously.
Planet of the Apps
starts coming up.
World tour, Cannes coming.
He's gonna spend
more time in L.A.
He's going to Chattanooga.
He's gonna be in London.
Sort of touch base
with all the offices.
Keeps you going day by
day so it's pretty fun.
- [Gary] Like
there's nothing else.
Either you're making decisions
for short-term
money or you're not.
- [Chi] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- And so people
that do the best shit,
care about their legacy
and the people that don't,
care about their wallet.
- [Chi] Mmmm.
- What the people that
care about their wallet
don't understand is if you're
really smart, you can have both.
I don't know if you've
asked this of them or
they've shared this,
I do not micromanage.
I mean I barely
even talk to Claude,
Steven, James.
- Okay.
- I'm real big believer in like
letting people do their thing.
- Okay.
- That's why I use the
American governors analogy.
- Mhmmm.
- Like you'd be the
governor of Florida.
Do your thing.
Run your shit.
- So the team
leads are important.
Have a good relationship.
- [Gary] Massive.
- Creative, strategy.
- [Gary] Massive,
massive and honestly
that's the vulnerability
here for people.
- Okay.
- [Gary] If I don't think
they're bought into that,
they get fired.
- [Chi] Okay.
- And I really don't give
a shit how good they are.
- [Chi] Yeah, yeah, sure.
- It's just imperative.
- [Chi] Yeah.
- It's where agencies break.
- [Chi] Yeah, yeah, sure, sure.
- It's allowing one
sector to think it's got
a bigger ego than the others.
- [Chi] Yeah, sure.
- It is the vulnerability.
I'm trying to audit for
myself, the structure of the
DNA of the human being--
- [Chi] Mhmmm.
- [Gary] to understand if
they have ego and humility.
- [Chi] Mhmmm, mhmmm. Cool.
- [Gary] Self-awareness
and empathy.
Passion and vision, right?
These are the core ingredients
that make a good dish.
- [Chi] I think you probably
have pretty good skills at
spotting that from a distance.
- [Gary] Yes and no.
Here's what
I think I'm good at, yes.
- Right.
- [Gary] Intuition has
been the beacon of my life.
- Mhmmm.
- [Gary] But I've missed.
And I've missed often.
Hiring is hard.
Investing is hard.
- [Chi] Yes, yes, yes.
- [Gary] Predicting is hard.
What I'm really good at
is adjusting to reality.
- Mhmmm.
- And so, when somebody comes,
has this serious of ambition
within the organization I always
want to be frank with them of
the things that are
running through my mind.
And what are the
lines in the sand?
The lines in the sand
are the logo trumps everything.
- Mhmmm.
- Everything's individual.
I'm not crippled by
we're this, we're that.
We're this and
that in every situation.
I'm just good at auditing and
understanding when this or that.
- [Chi] Yeah.
- Leader
because I'm agnostic.
- Uh-huh.
- [Gary] Everybody's my homies.
They're all my team.
I want them all to win.
I don't listen to you about your
feedback and your strategies
without them giving me...
- [Chi] Mhmmm.
- [Gary] I'm just
not a corporation.
- [Chi] Mhmmm.
- [Woman] If you had to
describe yourself in one word
what would that word be?
- A contradiction.
- [Woman] Cool.
- I think I'm pulling from the
very opposite sides which
give me real balance.
- [Woman] Yeah.
- I'm macro patient as fuck.
I just told you it's
gonna take four years,--
- [Woman] Yeah.
- but we're gonna move faster
in the micro than anybody.
- [Woman] Yeah.
- Got it?
- [Woman] Yep.
- So I think that.
I think I'm balanced because
I'm pulling very aggressively.
I'm more Chief Heart
Officer than Claude and
I'm more CFO than Alan.
- [Woman] (chuckles) Yeah.
- [Gary] And that's why I
wanted to make it very clear to
everybody up there
that this is my decision.
Whatever you like or don't
like, I've got to take that
responsibility
'cause it's the truth.
- [Woman] Yeah.
- They have impact,
everybody has a little impact.
- [Woman] No, totally.
That makes sense.
Awesome.
- Cool.
- [Woman] Yeah, I appreciate it.
- Thank you.
- [Woman] Nice to
sit down with you.
- Have a great day.
- [Woman] Yeah, you too.
("Stay Down" by TJO)
- [Gary] My responsibility is to
help us get somewhere and
I'll do whatever
it takes to do that.
And if that comes out of
something that's
painful to everybody to
remind them they should talk to
me then and that's good.
I can?
- [Sean] It's a muscle.
- It's a muscle isn't it?
Fuck, man,
I really, you know what?
For some reason the
way you just said it to me.
I'm gonna become
a rapper I think.
I might, I've
never taken a lesson.
I've never tried.
I've always only,
you know what's so funny?
I believe in my shit the most.
I triple down on all my
strengths which is why I don't
work on shit.
- [Sean] Yeah.
- I think I might have
to work on being a rapper.
Because I think I could be the
biggest rapper in the world.
We have the luxury of
putting out so much content,
we know it's popping.
We know it's
going viral as fuck.
We know that people are worried
about other people's opinions
and that the reason people don't
take the first step is they're
worried about other people.
The reason I only
do my thing is I don't.
("Stay Down" by TJO)
I hate when people try to think,
the Patriots and the
Cults sucked shit my whole life.
Until they got Peyton
and fuckin' Tom, right?
People don't get it.
It just doesn't matter.
The Lakers are bad when
Kobe and Shaq aren't there.
- [Man 2] Mhmmm.
- Like all you
need is, yeah, man.
All you need is a moment.
You know, I think
one of the things that,
you know, it's
kind of an interesting.
You okay, Sid?
Show Sid.
Sid's very excited because
multiple pieces of content that
have been translated across
the globe have gone viral.
Sid are you happy?
- [Sid] Very happy.
- [Gary] Okay, good.
Back to me.
While I said that please
show the pieces of content
that have gone viral.
Can you guys dig up the
pieces that have gone viral?
Cool.
Now to the point,
the meat of this episode,
is the following: when you have
full bravado and leadership and
you're a leader the number one
thing to feel comfortable with
is saying you're wrong,
changing the course,
having that humility
to go along with that ego.
I love navigating
such a big business.
Making decisions and
immediately being like nope.
Whether it's
hiring and firing,
whether it's
strategy of product,
whether it's client services,
whether it's teams
that you put together.
Something that has been rearing
it's head over the last year is
my comfort, more than ever,
'cause I think it's compounded
with experience, get to
that place where you are
in love with I'm wrong.
Let's change this.
I thought this yesterday.
I think this today.
I'm obsessed.
Do that every day as an
operator and you will win.
My dad used to say to me,
"But you said this last week
"that we would never lower
the price on Pinor Noirs."
And I'm like,
"That was last week."
("Sundays" by
Charlie MixWelh)
Am I out?
Meeting with Pure,
can you hear me?
- [DRock] Not really.
- You can transcribe it.
- [DRock] Okay.
- Meeting with PureWow.
Phil Toronto's birthday.
See ya.